[Seriez-vous capable d’infliger une décharge
électrique de 450V à un parfait inconnu,
juste parce qu’un scientifique, en
blouse grise et à l’air austère,
vous en a donné l’ordre de façon
insistante et autoritaire ?]
Une décharge de 450 V ? Non…personne ferait
ça. On parle d’un truc potentiellement
mortel, là. Juste parce qu’on reçoit
l’ordre de le faire. Non, jamais de la vie.
Et pourtant, d’après une expérience menée dans
les années 60 par le psychologue américain Stanley
Milgram, ce sont 65% des gens qui seraient prêts
à infliger un traitement de ce genre, une décharge
de 450V, si on leur en donne l’ordre. C’est ce
que Milgram appelle la soumission à l’autorité.
L’expérience de Milgram est probablement
la plus connue de toutes les expériences de
psychologie sociale, et elle est aujourd’hui
largement passée dans la culture populaire,
de façon plus ou moins déformée. Et aujourd’hui
je voudrais vous en parler en détail,
et voire ce que cette expérience implique
vraiment sur le plan scientifique et éthique.
Avant d’entrer dans les détails, voyons d’abord
l’expérience dans ses grandes lignes,
telle qu’on la présente généralement.
Deux personnes sont invitées à participer à
une expérience qui porte soi-disant sur «la
mémoire et l’apprentissage». Ils sont reçus au
laboratoire par un scientifique en blouse grise,
qui tire au sort les rôles : l’un des deux sujets
sera le professeur, et l’autre sera l’élève.
[Dans une pièce, l’élève est attaché à une
chaise et ses poignets sont reliés à des
électrodes. On installe le professeur dans
une autre pièce, dans laquelle se trouve une
machine permettant d’envoyer à l’élève des
décharges électriques allant jusque’à 450V.
Le professeur fait faire un exercice
de mémorisation à l’élève, et reçoit
pour consigne de lui envoyer
une décharge à chaque erreur,
qui devient de plus en plus
importante. 15V à la première
erreur. 30V à la deuxième. 45V à la troisième.
Etc. Et la machine est graduée jusqu’à 450V.
En réalité tout cela est truqué : il
n’y a qu’un seul sujet à cet expérience,
c’est le professeur. L’élève est en fait un
acteur, complice de l’expérience. Il fait exprès
de se tromper et ne reçoit évidemment aucune
décharge, mais il crie pour faire semblant.
Quand les décharges augmentent, si celui qui
joue le sujet rechigne à l’idée de suivre
la consigne et de les envoyer, le scientifique
qui conduit l’expérience prend un air grave et
lui dit un truc du genre : «Continuez s’il
vous plait» pour le pousser à poursuivre.
Si le sujet continue de protester, le scientifique
utilise des phrases qui sont des injonctions de
plus en plus fortes et autoritaires, comme «Vous
n’avez pas d’autre choix, il faut continuer».]
L’expérience a alors deux issues possibles :
si malgré l’insistance répétée du scientifique,
le sujet choisi d’arrêter, on note jusqu’à
quel niveau de décharge il a osé aller. Et
sinon l’expérience s’arrête quand le sujet
atteint le maximum de la machine soit 450V.
Eh bien dans l’expérience
menée par Stanley Milgram,
65% des sujets ont été jusqu’au bout,
jusqu’à des décharges électriques de 450V.
Quasiment les 2/3 des gens seraient
donc prêts à torturer un inconnu,
simplement parce qu’on leur en a donné
l’ordre de façon suffisamment insistante.
Voilà, ça c’était la description rapide, et
pour mieux interpréter ce résultat choquant,
il va falloir rentrer dans les détails. Mais
avant ça, pour comprendre cette expérience,
il est important d’avoir en tête le
contexte historique et idéologique dans
lequel on se trouve à l’époque.
C’est le début des années 60,
la seconde guerre mondiale est finie depuis
seulement une quinzaine d’années. Et en avril 1961
s’ouvre à Jérusalem le procès d’Adolf Eichmann.
Eichmann était un criminel de guerre nazi qui
avait réussi à se cacher à la fin de la guerre,
avant de s’exiler en Argentine sous un faux nom.
Mais en mai 1960, Eichmann est
capturé par un commando du Mossad,
les services secrets israéliens, puis ramené
à Jérusalem pour y être jugé. Le procès est
intégralement filmé et diffusé dans le monde
entier, et sera un énorme événement médiatique.
Comme beaucoup d’accusés jugés avant
lui à Nuremberg, la défense d’Eichmann
consistera à affirmer qu’il ne faisait
rien d’autre que suivre les ordres,
obéir à l’autorité militaire. Ca ne le
sauvera pas de la condamnation à mort,
mais il tiendra cette ligne jusqu’au bout,
ses derniers mots avant de mourir auraient
d’ailleurs été : «Je n’ai fait qu’obéir
aux lois de la guerre, et à mon drapeau.»
Le procès d’Eichmann sera sera notamment
couvert pour le New Yorker par la philosophe
Hannah Arendt, qui semble aller dans le
sens de sa défense, en décrivant Eichmann
comme un homme insignifiant, un fonctionnaire
médiocre et sans convictions. Elle introduit
alors pour le décrire cette expression
restée célèbre «La banalité du mal».
Et c’est donc dans le contexte de ce procès
que le psychologue Stanley Milgram imagine
les détails de son expérience de soumission
à l’autorité. Il se demande si dans le fond,
la plupart des êtres humains ne seraient
pas capables de choses aussi impensables si
on leur en donne l’ordre. Pour le dire de façon
crue, Milgram, qui est lui-même d’origine juive,
se demande si nous ne serions pas
tous des Eichmann en puissance.
Dans une lettre à la National Science Foundation,
l’organisme qui finance ses recherches,
il explique même qu’il est convaincu que
si un gouvernement totalitaire prenait
le pouvoir aux Etats-Unis et voulait
instaurer un système de camp de la mort,
ils n’auraient pas de mal à trouver dans la
population américaine le personnel nécessaire.
Par ailleurs, on était en pleine guerre
froide. Les États-Unis cherchaient sans
cesse à se rassurer de leur supériorité vis-à-vis
du bloc de l’Est, et de leur côté les militaires
n’avaient pas de mal à obtenir des financements
pour des recherches plus ou moins douteuses.
Bref, le contexte jouera beaucoup dans la
façon dont Milgram va concevoir et conduire
son expérience. Alors maintenant voyons
les détails, car certains sont importants
et manquent dans la description rapide
qu’on fait généralement de l’expérience.
Tout d’abord, l’expérience a officiellement
débuté au mois d’août 1961, mais elle a été
précédée de nombreuses semaines d’études
pilotes, où Stanley Milgram a testé sur des
premiers sujets différentes configurations.
Il a soigneusement affiné son scénario
afin je cite «de créer la situation
d’obéissance la plus forte possible».
Une fois la conception terminée,
l’expérience a duré plusieurs mois,
jusqu’en mai 1962 et a mobilisé 780
participants au total. Et si c’est ce
chiffre est si important, c’est parce que
Milgram n’a pas réalisé *une* expérience,
mais 24 variations différentes de celle-ci,
chacune comprenant une quarantaine de sujets.
Celle que je vais vous décrire est la plus
connue, la variation numéro 5. Tout d’abord,
Milgram a souhaité recruter ses sujets dans
la population générale. A cette époque,
les expérience de psychologie utilisaient
surtout comme cobayes des étudiants de
l’université où ça se déroulait, voire carrément
des étudiants en psychologie. Donc pas forcément
très représentatifs de l’humanité dans son
ensemble. Milgram veut faire différemment.
Il choisit de diffuser une annonce dans
le journal local de la ville de New Haven,
où se trouve l’université de Yale où il travaille.
L’annonce dit qu’il cherche des hommes entre
20 et 50 ans pour une étude sur la mémoire. La
compensation prévue est de 4.50$ pour une heure de
présence. Aujourd’hui ça ferait environ 40€, donc
c’est a priori intéressant comme dédommagement.
Les candidats sont convoqués au
laboratoire de psychologie de Yale,
et on les soumets au tirage au sort
truqué, de sorte qu’ils ont forcément
le rôle du professeur. L’élève on l’a
dit est un acteur, toujours le même.
Petit détail dont on reparlera :
avant de commencer l’expérience,
on leur fait signer une décharge comme
quoi ils renoncent par avance à toute
action légale contre l’Université
de Yale, si jamais ça tournait mal.
L’élève, un acteur donc, est installé dans
une chaise située dans une première pièce,
tout ça sous les yeux du sujet. Au cours de
l’installation, l’acteur mentionne qu’il a
été récemment traité pour son coeur, et demande à
l’expérimentateur si l’expérience est dangereuse.
Ce dernier lui dit que non non, pas d’inquiétude.
Que ca peut être douloureux mais pas dangereux.
Ensuite le sujet est emmené dans la pièce à côté,
il ne voit plus l’élève, et on lui présente la
machine pour envoyer les décharges électriques.
C’est une machine imposante, très réaliste,
avec des interrupteurs, des lumières, un
cadran à aiguille pour le voltage, etc.
Il y a donc 30 interrupteurs, allant de 15V en
15V, jusqu’à 450V. Sous les interrupteurs il
y a des mentions : ça commence choc léger, choc
modéré et ça va jusqu’à choc d’intensité extrême,
danger : choc sévère. Et sous les 2 derniers
interrupteurs, il n’y a que la mention XXX.
Pour montrer au sujet ce que ça fait,
l’expérimentateur lui administre une vraie
décharge de 45V. Puis on lui explique l’exercice
de mémorisation qu’il devra faire passer à l’élève
: il devra d’abord lire une liste de paires de
mots à l’élève, par exemple «oiseau rapide»,
«cheval blanc», «nouveau livre», «gout
sucré». Puis ensuite l’interrogation commence.
Le sujet doit lire à haute voix des
questions prédéfinies comme un QCM.
Par exemple il dit «blanc», et
propose : nuage, cheval, caillou,
bâtiment. Ici la bonne réponse c’est la
deuxième, et l’élève dans l’autre pièce
répond non pas en parlant, mais en appuyant sur
un bouton qui allume une lumière 1,2 3 ou 4.
Si la réponse est bonne, le sujet doit
l’annoncer et poursuivre. Si elle est fausse,
il dit «faux», annonce la tension
de la décharge, par exemple 15 volts,
et enclenche l’interrupteur correspondant.
Evidemment tout le scénario est écrit
d’avance. L’élève, un acteur donc,
suit une liste prédéterminée de réponses, bonnes
ou fausses, et une bande sonore préenregistrée
diffuse parfois ses commentaires ou ses
cris, que le sujet entend à travers le mur.
La séquence commence comme ça :
bonne réponse, bonne réponse, erreur,
il reçoit une décharge de 15V, erreur à nouveau
30V, erreur 45V. Puis une bonne, deux fausses,
etc. A partir de 75V, l’élève commence à émettre
des sons à chaque décharge, du genre «Aïe».
A 120V, il dit «aïe ça fait vraiment mal».
150V «AÏE, expérimentateur, bon c’est tout
! Laissez moi sortir, je vous ai parlé de
mon problème de coeur. Mon coeur commence à
m’inquiéter maintenant, laissez moi sortir s’il
vous plait, mon coeur m’inquiète. Je refuse
de continuer, laissez moi sortir.» (22:40)
Et à partir de là, le script va crescendo.
A 195V il reparle de son coeur (25:30)
A partir de 270V, le script
précise : Cri d’agonie (28:00)
300V, après un nouveau crie d’agonie : «Je
refuse absolument de répondre à partir maintenant.
Laissez moi sortir, vous ne pouvez pas me garder
ici. Laissez moi, laissez moi sortir !». (28:25)
L’expérimentateur indique que si l’élève
refuse de répondre, il faut considérer ça
comme une mauvaise réponse. Et donc
administrer une nouvelle décharge.
A 330V, l’élève répète de façon frénétique :
laissez moi laissez moi sortir. (29:40) Puis
reste totalement silencieux, et ne répond
plus aux questions du test. Et le sujet
reçoit pour consigne de continuer à poser
les questions, et envoyer les décharges.
Evidemment on s’en doute, les sujets se trouvaient
très stressés par cette situation, et
se posaient des questions pour savoir
s’il fallait continuer. L’expérimentateur
suivait là-aussi un script très précis.
Si le sujet refusait de continuer
il disait d’abord «S’il vous plait,
continuez» Si le sujet résistait à cette
phrase, il utilisait une phrase plus forte
«L’experience requiert que vous continuiez».
Puis si nécessaire «il est absolument essentiel
de continuer». Et enfin «Vous n’avez
pas d’autre choix, vous devez continuer».
Si à un moment donné de l’expérience, le sujet
résistait à ces 4 phrases successivement,
cela mettait un terme à l’expérience, et
on notait le seuil maximum administré. Et
sinon l’expérience s’arrêtait quand le 30ème
niveau de décharge était atteint : 450 V.
Une fois l’expérience achevée, l’expérimentateur
révélait que l’expérience était truquée,
que l’élève était un acteur, qu’aucun
choc n’avait été administré, et que
les cris provenaient d’une bande préenregistrée.
C’était la phase de révélation de la supercherie.
La version de l’expérience que je vous ai
présentée ici, c’est donc la version n°5,
la plus connue, celle dont Milgram a publié les
résultats en 1963. Elle a mobilisé 40 sujets,
mais au total les 24 versions de l’expérience
auront nécessité 780 participants. Et on
va évoquer plusieurs de ces versions, mais
voyons d’abord ce qu’a d’abord publié Milgram.
En 1963, Milgram parvient à faire publier son
article dans la revue Journal of Abnormal and
Social Psychology. Il rapporte alors que 26
sujets sur 40, 65% donc, ont été jusqu’au seuil
maximum de 450V. Et les 14 sujets restants ont
tous été au-delà de 300V. Sachant que dès 150V,
l’élève commençait à rappeler ses problèmes
de coeur, à dire que son coeur l’inquiétait.
Dans l’introduction de son article scientifique,
Milgram faisait explicitement référence au
régime nazi et aux camps de concentration,
et positionnait donc directement son
expérience comme un élément de réponse.
Très vite, l’article a été repris par la
presse grand public : par le New-York Times,
l’agence United Press, puis dans
un grand nombre de magazines aux
Etats-Unis et au Royaume Uni. Il faut
dire que l’idée que nous serions tous
des nazis en puissance avait
de quoi attirer le lecteur.
Alors regardons un peu de façon
critique ces résultats. Pour commencer,
est-ce que scientifiquement la découverte est
robuste. Il y a 40 sujets, c’est pas énorme.
Et généralement ce qu’on fait dans une expérience
de ce genre, c’est d’avoir un groupe de contrôle.
Par exemple quand on évalue un médicament,
on peut le comparer à un placebo.
Alors qu’ici on a juste un seul groupe,
avec 65% des gens qui vont jusqu’à 450V. Ok mais
c’est quoi l’équivalent du groupe de contrôle.
On peut répondre de deux manières. La première,
c’est que dans une de ses variations de
l’expérience, Milgram a effectivement fait
ce qu’on peut considérer comme une variante
de contrôle. C’est la variation n°14,
qu’il avait baptisé «Carte Blanche».
Dans cette variante, on présentait le
fonctionnement de la machine au sujet,
mais sans instruction précise sur quand envoyer
des décharges et lesquelles. Il pouvait de
lui-même choisir le niveau qu’il administrait
à n’importe quel moment. Dans cette variation,
1 seul sujet a été jusqu’à utiliser
l’interrupteur 450V. Donc grosse différence.
L’autre manière de voir les choses,
c’est de dire que ce chiffre de 65%,
il n’a pas vraiment besoin de groupe
de contrôle. 65%, c’est super choquant.
Ca aurait été 50 ou 80 ça n’aurait pas
changé grand chose. Le groupe de contrôle,
c’est notre intuition naturelle qu’un tel truc
était impossible, que ça aurait dû être zéro.
Pour tester et quantifier cette intuition,
Milgram avait imaginé un protocole, c’est la
variante n°21. Il a réuni des professeurs
de l’université de Yale, il leur a décrit
l’expérience et leur a demandé de prédire quel
pourcentage des sujets iraient jusqu’à 450V.
Eh bien ils ont prédit que la plupart
des sujets n’iraient pas au-delà de 150V,
que moins de 5% atteindraient 300V et
que seul 0.1%, une personne sur mille,
oserait aller jusque’à 450V. A comparer
à ce qui s’est passé : 65%. Pas besoin
de groupe de contrôle quand on a un
résultat qui défie autant l’intuition.
Maintenant l’autre question qu’il faut se
poser, c’est : est-ce que l’expérience est
valide scientifiquement. On le sait, Milgram
était ambitieux, il voulait absolument obtenir
un résultat frappant, et il a réussi. Est-ce
qu’on peut avoir confiance dans le résultat ?
Ca n’est pas anodin comme question. Quelques
années plus tard, un autre chercheur en
psychologie, Philip Zimbardo conduira une
autre expérience restée célèbre, celle de
la prison de Stanford. Et un travail récent d’un
chercheur français, Thibaut Le Texier, a dépeint
l’expérience de Zimbardo comme quasi-frauduleuse
et relevant plus du cinéma que de la science.
Alors est-ce que ça pourrait être la même
chose avec Milgram ? Est-ce que l’expérience
pourrait avoir été plus ou moins truquée
? A priori non, mais il y a quelques zones
d’ombre. La première concerne l’attitude de
l’expérimentateur, celui qui donne les ordres.
Ca n’était pas Milgram lui-même, c’était
quelqu’un qu’il avait embauché pour l’occasion,
pour tenir ce rôle. Or il semble qu’à de
nombreuses reprises, l’expérimentateur se
soit écarté du script, notamment sur les phrases
destinées à «mettre la pression» sur le sujet.
On l’a dit, il y avait en principe 4 phrases
d’intensité croissante, et si le sujet résistait
au 4 à la suite, l’expérience devait s’arrêter.
Sauf que ça ne s’est pas toujours passé comme ça.
En 2012 la psychologue australienne
Gina Perry a sorti un livre très
complet, le résultat d’un travail
d’investigation de plusieurs années,
au cours duquel elle a creusé tous les
dessous de l’expérience de Milgram.
Pour écrire son livre, qui s’appelle «Behind
the shock machine» Gina Perry a écouté des
centaines d’heures d’enregistrements
des expériences de Milgram. Car oui,
les expériences étaient enregistrées. Et ces
enregistrements ont révélé qu’à de nombreuses
reprises, l’expérimentateur ne s’arrêtait
pas comme il l’aurait dû, après 4 relances.
Gina Perry a compté que dans certains
cas, il pouvait insister jusqu’à plus
de 10 fois avant de concéder l’arrêt de
l’expérience. Alors est-ce que ça invalide
les résultats? Pas forcément de façon majeure,
le protocole était tout de même très cadré,
mais ça montre que des libertés ont
parfois été prises avec le script.
De toute façon vous le savez, ce qui
compte dans ce genre d’expériences,
c’est de savoir si elles ont été répliquées
par d’autres chercheurs. Et il semble que
oui. Dans une revue du sujet, le psychologue
Thomas Blass a dénombré entre 1967 et 1985
pas moins de 18 réplications de l’expérience de
Milgram aux États-Unis et dans d’autres pays.
Et les taux d’obéissance, si on les appelle
comme ça, s’étalaient entre 30 et 85%,
avec une moyenne de 66%. Ce qui semble aller
dans le sens de la répétabilité de l’expérience.
Un point qui vous a peut-être fait tiquer
quand je vous ai parlé de la chronologie,
c’est le fait que Milgram
a passé plusieurs semaines
à faire des tests préliminaires et
affiner le design de l’expérience.
En gros, avant de commencer vraiment
l’expérience, il a tout ajusté pour
être sûr d’obtenir les résultats qu’il
voulait. Est-ce que c’est correct ça,
scientifiquement parlant ? Est-ce
que c’est pas limite de la fraude ?
Alors non, je ne crois pas que ce soit
une mauvaise conduite scientifique.
Après tout il est courant qu’un chercheur
qui veuille observer un certain phénomène
naturel se mette dans les meilleures
circonstances possibles pour l’observer.
C’est ce qu’a voulu faire Milgram, il a
voulu créer une situation bien spécifique
dans laquelle il était sûr que le phénomène
de soumission à l’autorité fonctionnerait à
plein régime. Ca ne pose pas de problème
sur le plan de la rigueur scientifique.
Par contre ça en pose un sérieux sur la
portée et l’interprétation des résultats.
La vrai question de l’expérience de Milgram,
ça n’est pas : est-ce que les résultats du
protocole sont corrects ? Manifestement ils
le sont. Mais c’est plutôt : qu’est-ce
qu’on peut en conclure d’intéressant ?
Déjà, on peut se demander si les participants
y croyaient vraiment. Milgram l’avait estimé
à partir d’un questionnaire, et 44% des
participants exprimaient avoir au minimum des
doutes sur la réalité de l’expérience. Et plus les
participants y croyaient, moins ils obéissaient.
Les participants qui y croyaient complètement ont
obéi à seulement 38% au lieu de 65% en moyenne.
Il faut savoir aussi que l’expérience
a duré presque un an, que la ville de
New Haven, où se trouve l’Université de Yale,
n’est pas si grande que ça, et que la rumeur
de l’existence de l’expérience truquée a pu
avoir le temps de se répandre dans la ville.
Mais admettons que les participants
y croyaient de bonne foi. Malgré
tout : qu’est-ce que ça prouve ? On l’a
dit, toute la motivation scientifique de
Milgram est construite autour de
l’idée d’expliquer l’Holocauste,
et le comportement de toutes les personnes
qui ont été des rouages de cette machine.
Milgram pensait avoir expliqué
les horreurs du nazisme avec son
expérience. Ca se voit assez bien
dans les sous-titres qu’il avait
imaginé pour son livre «Obedience
to authority»,qui paraitra en 1974.
On a retrouvé dans ses notes un certain
nombres de titres de travail comme «Votre
voisin est-il un Eichmann en puissance
?»,«Où est Eichmann ? Regardez-vous
dans le miroir !» ou encore «Si Eichmann avait
lu ce livre, il ne serait pas devenu Eichmann».
Donc la vrai question que pose cette
expérience, c’est : est-ce qu’elle
nous apprend quoi que ce soit d’utile pour
comprendre des événements comme l’Holocauste,
ou les crimes contre l’humanité en général.
Et la réponse c’est … probablement pas.
Le fait que Milgram ait créé une situation
si spécifique, si génialement conditionnée,
fait qu’on peut difficilement extrapoler les
résultats au-delà de cette situation précise.
Il y a beaucoup de différences essentielles
entre l’expérience de Milgram, et ce qu’il
a pu se passer dans le cas de génocides. Car oui,
une expérience de labo n’est pas la «vraie vie».
Voyons un peu. En 1960 aux USA, les gens
vivent dans une démocratie, on les fait
venir dans un labo de recherche scientifique
à Yale, une des plus célèbres universités du
monde. C’est un contexte hyper rassurant
pour des gens qui vivent dans cette ville.
Ils sont reçus dans le labo, par des chercheurs,
c’est-à-dire des experts de leurs sujets. Les
sujets ont confiance dans ce qu’il va se passer.
Ils sont là pour faire avancer la recherche,
une noble cause, et ils ont à coeur de ne
pas ruiner une expérience scientifique.
C’est assez différent des situations d’obéissance
dans lesquelles ont dû se retrouver les personnes
impliquées dans des crimes contre l’humanité. Une
distinction importante soulignée par le philosophe
Steve Patten dans un de ses articles,
c’est la nature de l’autorité impliquée.
Dans l’expérience de Milgram, on a affaire
à une autorité «basée sur l’expertise».
L’expérimentateur donne des ordres, mais sa
légitimité vient de son expertise scientifique
de chercheur. Cela contraste avec le cas d’une
autorité «simple», non-basée sur l’expertise,
et dans laquelle quelqu’un donne des ordres
juste par ce que c’est lui le chef désigné.
Dans l’expérience de Milgram, le chercheur,
en position d’expert, assure qu’il n’y a aucun
danger. Les gens y croient, et d’ailleurs
ils ont bien raison d’y croire puisque c’est
vrai ! L’expérience était truquée, donc
il n’y avait effectivement aucun danger.
C’est quand même très différent d’un
génocide, où certains participants
sont forcément parfaitement conscients de ce
qu’ils sont en train de faire à leurs victimes.
Une autre différence importante concerne
l’échelle de temps. L’expérience de Milgram
ne dure qu’une heure, alors qu’un génocide
se déroule sur des mois voire des années.
Pas exactement la même chose quand il
s’agit de réaliser la portée de ses actes.
Et puis comme le montrent les enregistrements
et les images de l’époque, les sujets de
l’expérience étaient très loins de l’obéissance
aveugle. On sentait clairement qu’ils luttaient,
qu’ils étaient contre ce qui était en
train de se passer. Mais à cause de
l’autorité de l’expert et des mécanismes
de manipulations psychologiques imaginés
par Milgram, les sujets n’arrivaient pas
à traduire cette opposition en actes.
Aujourd’hui, il semble que le consensus
parmi les chercheurs en psychologie soit
de considérer l’expérience de Milgram
comme «scientifiquement valide»,
mais de jeter de gros doutes quant
à une trop large interprétation,
notamment pour prétendre expliquer des
choses comme des crimes contre l’humanité.
On pourrait donc considérer l’expérience
de Milgram comme une curiosité,
sans grande portée scientifique réelle. Mais
un dernier point dont il faut absolument parler
quand on évoque cette expérience,
car il s’agit peut-être d’une de
ses répercussions les plus importantes,
c’est le problème éthique qu’elle pose.
Ce sujet a largement été exploré par Gina
Perry pour son livre dont j’ai parlé, et je
me suis beaucoup appuyé sur ce texte pour mieux
comprendre les ressorts éthiques de l’expérience.
Gina Perry a notamment passé 4 ans à fouiller
les 158 caisses d’archives de Milgram,
interviewer des sujets de l’expérience.
Et elle a fait quelques découvertes pour
le moins troublantes, sur des éléments de
l’histoire soigneusement cachés par Milgram.
[jingle]
Pour commencer, il n’y a pas besoin de réfléchir
très longtemps pour se dire que l’expérience vécue
par les 780 sujets de l’expérience de Milgram
a dû être assez traumatisante. Combien de ces
780 sujets sont sortis de là convaincus qu’ils
étaient des nazis en puissance ? Gina Perry a
pu en interviewer plusieurs, qui des décennies
après en gardent encore un traumatisme.
A ce sujet, la défense de Milgram a
toujours été qu’à la fin de l’expérience,
il prenait le temps d’expliquer
qu’il s’agissait d’une supercherie,
que personne n’avait été blessé. Et que les
sujets ressortaient de l’expérience sans aucun
traumatisme, en étant même heureux d’avoir
participé à une expérience scientifique.
Pour Milgram, la révélation de la supercherie
juste à la fin l’expérience était censée
dissiper tout malentendu. Le seul problème,
c’est que cette défense de Milgram est
quasi-mensongère. Gina Perry a découvert
que sur les 780 sujets de l’expérience,
seulement 1/4 avaient effectivement été informés
de la supercherie à la fin de l’expérience.
Les autres, pas loin de 600 personnes donc,
sont ressortis du labo de Milgram en étant
plus ou moins convaincus qu’ils venaient de
filer 450V à un pauvre innocent. Et certains
n’ont appris la vérité que plusieurs
mois après la fin de l’expérience.
Il semble en fait que pour les 16 premières
variantes, Milgram ait soigneusement omis de
révéler la vérité au sujets, probablement pour
éviter que l’histoire ne se répande dans la
ville de New Haven, ce qui risquait à ses yeux
de compromettre la validité de l’expérience.
Evidemment, on peut s’en douter, certains
des malheureux sujets sont allés se plaindre
à l’administration de l’Université de Yale.
Bon rappelez vous quand même qu’ils avaient
signé une décharge les interdisant de toute
poursuite judiciaire envers l’Université.
Malgré tout Yale a quand même été
obligée de conduire une enquête,
et l’a confiée à un psychiatre de l’université.
Son rapport fut relativement rassurant,
mais Milgram l’a fait publier avec le
sous-titre «basé sur les 40 cas les pires»,
alors que d’après Gina Perry, d’une part
il n’y avait que 32 cas, et d’autre part,
ça n’était pas les pires mais simplement les
32 qui avaient répondu à l’appel. Sur 780.
Un cas particulièrement choquant relaté par Gina
Perry concerne la variante n°24 de l’expérience,
dont l’existence est restée secrète
pendant des décennies. Dans cette variante,
Milgram a fait participer des gens par deux,
en prenant des personnes qui se
connaissaient : amis, voisins, famille.
On tirait au sort le professeur et l’élève,
et le participant qui jouait l’élève était
alors mis dans la confidence. On lui demandait
de jouer l’acteur, et de simuler la souffrance
selon le script établi par Milgram. Dans cette
variante, seulement 15% des gens sont allés
jusqu’à 450V, mais on se demande ce que cette
expérience a pu avoir comme effet sur eux.
A noter pour l’anecdote que Milgram avait
même envisagé une variante «mari et femme»,
mais qu’il ait quand même finalement
réalisé que là, ça allait trop loin.
Malgré tout, l’expérience a déclenché pas mal de
controverses dans le milieu de la psychologie,
et a conduit finalement l’American Psychological
Association, a modifier son règlement en 1973.
Elle a notamment introduit des règles éthiques
pour un meilleur consentement des sujets,
l’interdiction de toute forme de
souffrance physique ou psychologique,
et le droit inaliénable pour les sujets de
se retirer à tout moment d’une expérience.
L’expérience de Milgram aura au moins servi
à ça, et elle est devenu de fait impossible
à reproduire en l’état aujourd’hui. C’est
maintenant une expérience interdite.
Quoiqu’il en soit elle fait maintenant
partie de la culture populaire,
on la trouve mentionnée dans une chanson de
Peter Gabriel, dans le film «I comme Icare»
de Henri Verneuil. Et elle a aussi donné lieu
à plusieurs émissions de télé, dont une assez
catastrophique à mon goût, en France en 2010.
Certains d’entre vous l’ont peut-être vue.
Aujourd’hui on peut sérieusement
se demander quel statut accorder
au résultats de l’expérience de Milgram. Peut-on
vraiment parler d’un résultat scientifique ? Ou
est-ce qu’il s’agit plus d’une curiosité
historique, et maintenant anachronique ?
Dans la conclusion de son livre, Gina
Perry se demande si finalement il ne
faudrait pas considérer l’expérience de
Milgram comme une sorte de performance,
presque artistique, destinée
simplement à servir de métaphore ?
Voilà c’est tout pour aujourd’hui,
j’espère avoir donné un éclairage complet
et honnête sur cette expérience parfois
maltraitée. Je me suis beaucoup basé sur le
livre de Gina Perry que je vous recommande.
Comme toujours, je donne encore quelques
détails dans le billet de blog qui accompagne
la vidéo. Abonnez-vous, mettez la cloche si
vous voulez être certains de ne pas louper
les nouveaux épisodes, et je vous dit
à très bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo.